the tournament is over so what can you
say what would be the what was the
outcome of this event here yeah it's
kind of happiness it's over
because um
i think i actually played a little bit
better than the result may indicate but
actually i don't know what's the reason
why they were here
it's kind of difficult to say that's
resistance
um i guess i just
maybe i wasn't with sending the pressure
it's crucial pressure moments because it
was usually like around 14 moves so
um
yeah however all there is and
i will have a
i mean a lot of conclusions i guess from
this tournament so in that aspect it's
it's fine yeah you as you mentioned it
was actually um you can just tournament
it was the first time that you
participated there so the difference is
this enormous pressure probably but can
you say that you have done everything
you prepared a lot because we heard the
news that you were preparing for a few
months so what do you think
yes yes i did uh perhaps i should have
played some critical tournament along
the way because
my last uh
tournament priority candidates was in
bygone z actually was in january so that
was uh i mean every year and perhaps i
was playing a bit you know like so
intuitively like playing in faster time
controls so um
i mean it was kind of i guess difficult
to adjust so
yeah definitely i mean i have done
something wrong uh because um
otherwise i mean
i wouldn't do the minus three
yeah but today's game was a very
interesting fight and uh very happy with
the special g6 move today
yes um yeah actually it seems so
surprising and so
um so in that aspect it was fine now i
mean
[Music]
i mean we got kind
kind of tense position after the opening
and
my opponent was on the pressure but so
was i
and
yeah i wasn't feeling like particularly
you know like happy about my position
like i knew he was just okay but
acquired a lot of calculations and
i mean today i wasn't i was kind of
sleepy actually uh so
probably wasn't like the best position
you know to get but
yeah
i mean
i guess it was kind of
probably a very logical game i mean
relatively in taking into account
how complicated he was
and what are your future plans what i'm
going to do after this event yeah they
were playing olympia in chennai in two
weeks yeah poland actually performed
quite well in the olympics and what are
you looking forward this time
yes you are looking to
have a good time again
in chennai and hopefully i get some
middle
thank you very much
in the next tournament thank you